der 5 attraktiv söhne aber nur einer von
ihnen soll erben bei denen von anhalts
da hängt der haussegen mächtig schief
und grund dafür sind die pläne von
adoptivpapa prinz frederic von anhalt
das dessen von georgia gabor geerbte
millionen soll dann irgendwann an kevin
feucht gehen prinz frederik hatte den
27-jährigen jahr unlängst genau dafür
auch adoptiert aus einer jahrelangen
freundschaft wurden väterliche gefühle
dann die adoption also mit option auf
das millionenerbe und das schmeckt den
anderen adoptivsöhne allen voran prinz
alexander von anhalt natürlich gar nicht
da fragen wir doch einfach bei alexander
von anhalt er ist jetzt bei uns bei bild
live schönen guten tag
in ihre nation gar und goldkettchen
hallo was sage ich ihr so bin ich nun
mal da ist ihr adoptivvater
seinem neuen adoptivsohn das gesamte
erbe vermachen will wie finden sie das
also von mir aus kann ein alles geld
geben was er hat ist mir egal wie gesagt
meinte glaube ich nicht ich habe
irgendwann von 60 millionen gelesen ich
denke mal da ist null zu viel aber geld
interessiert mich auch nicht wieso ich
habe selber geld ich brauche dann die
hatten die chargers millionen brauche
ich auch nicht und so weiter alles was
mich einfach aufregt was mich emotional
mitnimmt traurig macht aber auch
gleichzeitig wütend ist dass er
grundsätzlich in den medien in den
medien immer sagt die anderen söhne die
sind alle schlägt mit dem will ich
nichts mehr zu tun ab jetzt sagt dabei
mir sagte er noch ich habe gar nicht
gewusst dass der mit dem rotlicht zu tun
hat da habe ich später erfahren frederik
selbst dazu sie ist jetzt
swingerclubs haben nichts mit rot nicht
zu tun ich habe nichts mit honig zu tun
ich glaube du selber ich habe mal
gelesen hollywood reporter hat selber
gesagt dass du punkt in dortmund hat es
damals gefordert nachgegangen also mach
doch dann auch dann gut nicht so
schlecht mensch gehört auch mit dem mist
da darf man nicht mehr in der in der in
der familie ja da streitet man sich auch
mal das ist ganz einfach so da muss man
sich auch mal wieder zusammenraufen
mensch care wir haben so eine schöne
geile zeit gehabt ich habe so schöne
bilder mit irgendwann so schön gewesen
um auf - plus paris wo er mit sascha
essen gewesen war wir haben so eine
schöne zeit gehabt und jetzt auf einmal
hören und sehen nichts mehr von ihm und
dann sehe ich diese berichte dann seid
jetzt hat er schon wieder adoptiert man
von mir aus kann auch 100 heute
adoptieren aber ich mache mir langsam
gedanken
früher habe ich ihn immer gesehen mit
champagner party feiern und so weiter
und so fort jetzt geht dahin dann hat
das warten auf den taschen die an katar
verkauft 10 millionen dann müssten wir
dann auch abrechnet ich dort et cetera
und so weiter und was da bleibt da kaum
geld übrig und was muss ich dann was
muss ich dann sehen da war ich hab ich
da jetzt schluss jetzt sehe ich ihn auf
einmal auf dem bild mit jägermeister
fleisch hat danach ich mir halt so doch
gedanken wann ist damit papa jetzt los
kann das sein dass ein riesiges gekickt
hat damals die mama gestorben ist war
kann noch alle die wahrheit wenn ja so
einfach nicht immer sagen die söhne sind
schlecht dieses böse er will mit dem sie
nichts zu tun haben verstehe ich nicht
für mich ich schreibe ihn anzurufen geht
keiner dran letzten mal mehr sehe ich
noch wandern straßen da die so papa und
darin bewegt er sich auf einen moment
gewesen habe ich unser wald ist ja auf
toilette und auch so benannt hat man ja
auch natürlich ganz klar eine schwache
blase deutlich das verzeihe ich noch ne
aber am telefon geht doch nie es sonnig
manchester jetzt hat er adoptiert hat er
den capitano optiert habe ich noch
niemanden gesehen und so weiter und so
fort ja ich wünsche dem team alles gute
ich hätte natürlich mir gewünscht dass
der junge bisschen anstand gehabt wird
und sich natürlich erstmal wahrsagen
wussten worauf vorgestellt und gesagt
mensch der alles guck mal hier ich bin
ein neuer ich erzähle die seien ja komm
du bist ja auch noch jung du brauchst
ein bisschen geld in der tasche du musst
wissen dann wieder leben aber ob er
hinter ihr kriegt naja dann steht wieder
auf einer ganz anderen seite der
medaille weil papa hat ja auch in igls
in der tasche und tut ja auch nicht
gerne so schön werden schwierigkeiten
und feucht gar nicht der letzte
adoptivsohn ihres vaters sein wird sowie
sich anhört hat er ja eine extreme
leidenschaft eine sammelleidenschaft für
adoptiv kinder also da kann vielleicht
noch einiges passieren aber ja unter
normalen umständen bei normalen menschen
würde man jetzt sagen mein gott ja wie
sie schon gesagt haben brauchen sie sich
doch zusammen schicken sie meine
whatsapp jetzt gerade zum jahresende
oder zu weihnachten irgendwie man man
muss doch versuchen da irgendwie
miteinander auszukommen man hat ja auch
eine gute zeit miteinander ist da
wirklich gar nichts mehr zu retten
frederik ist ja ein dickkopf genauso wie
ich er hat einmal gesagt die anderen
alle ohne interessant aber gesagt alles
so ich dir kommen beide aus dem ruhrpott
er kam aus dortmund aber gesagt wir sind
so hat er gesagt der dissen im ruhrpott
wie die sache läuft wir sind harte kerle
ja so als war dann wie kopf ich habe ihn
angeschrieben ich habe den eindruck der
meldet sich doch gar nicht bei mir und
verstehe ich nicht hab ich noch nichts
getan meine güte ich hab mir bilder in
die tasche doch sonst immer schöne
geschenke mitgebracht wenn ich gekommen
bin von mama schöne bulgari kohli hat
der schönen benutzte alter noch das
schöne goldene dem feuerzeug wo ich mir
schon ein avatar prinz vertrag und ich
habe mich doch nicht lumpen lassen ich
war doch immer ein guter sohn gewesen
und jetzt da ich will mit dem nichts zu
tun hat ich habe erfahren hat mit ruhig
zu tun genau das gucken wir uns noch mal
ganz kurz sagen das gucken wir uns
einmal ganz kurz an wasser sagt die
haben wir natürlich gefragt und frederic
von anhalt sagt genau das hier wie
gerade schon von ihnen beschrieben also
der passt einfach nicht in meine
gesellschafter alexander deshalb will
ich keinen kontakt mehr mit ihm ich habe
mich immer unter präsidentin und
hollywood-stars bewegt nicht unter also
nicht in unter seinesgleichen von
alexanders aktivitäten im
rotlicht-milieu habe ich lange nichts
gewusst sagt er also das ist die
begründung dass sie raus
neues müssen sich das mal überlegen
ja da kriege ich ja schon wieder so eine
krawatte wenn ich das schon wieder sehen
wir derzeit kommen auf meiner website er
sagt unter präsident und hollywood-stars
ja unter dem aber nicht mit doch alle
wirklich anwenden hergekommen bist bin
ich irgendwo angekommen und habe ich
gesagt ich bin da alexander der prinz
alexander ja sagt van eck und sascha gab
ja da haben die leute guckt dann dias
hand von jakarta
und wenn ihr gesagt habe ja prinz
frederik
das in die hecke ran ich sage ist denn
jetzt hier los kommt dann auf meiner
seite ich bin ja auch mit den leuten
unterwegs und machen und tun so weiter
ich kann natürlich auch in dem
irgendwelche fotos mal auf wenn ich zum
beispiel ich war der erste deutsche
prinz aus den oscar ward auf den oscar
wird das war kein deutscher prinz
frederik nicht auf den oscar walthier
warf den globes und so weiter und so
fort jahr aber ist egal ist und ich sage
einfach nur wissen seiner familie ist
mir wichtiger als geld
deshalb muss man ja von irgendetwas
leben das ist ja klar also sie wirken
natürlich jetzt nicht als hätten sie
nicht ich weiß ja nicht ob das sei alles
echt das was sie da sagen aber so ein
paar milliönchen mehr oder weniger das
macht ja schon ein unterschied oder nein
nicht wenn es in der familie ist da geht
es nicht darum in einer familie soll es
nicht um geld gehen ja das ist ganz ganz
wichtig weil geld gibt immer
streitigkeit es nicht will keinen streit
aber warum sich denn damals überhaupt
adoptieren lassen das war der hauptgrund
ach ja wir haben uns ja schon lange
bekannt dass region ist ja so und da ist
der vater
ist ein vater sohn verließ entstand ja
und ich muss ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen
das weiß keiner also ja ich sage es
jetzt hier ich sage es jetzt hier das
weiß keiner wissen mein leiblicher vater
ja wenn meine mutter damals sich nicht
von ihm getrennt wäre dann würde ich mir
ziemlich reden ja der hat getrunken der
hat meine mutter geschlagen der hat
nicht geschlagen und ich will mit dem
gar nichts mehr zu tun haben ich habe
mit dem jahrelang schon ich glaube
letzte mal da war ich zwölf oder so
gewesen habe ich mit ihm zu tun gehabt
und dann war ich natürlich froh gewesen
da habe ich natürlich eine vaterfigur
habe dass ich natürlich jemand habe
zudem nicht ausschauen kann heute schaue
ich da nicht mehr raus ja weil ich sage
mal frederik meine hähnchenmast ihr
klamotten das war für mich der grund
unnatürlich hollywood ich habe ja
wirklich man hat mir die furten geöffnet
ich bin jetzt überall rein gekommen wo
sie ja sogar nicht reinkommen ja das war
natürlich das schöne mit dem titel na
schön dass man gesagt hat mensch das ist
eine tolle sache aber der titel war ja
gar nicht der vordergrund ist ich wollte
einfach einen schönen familienfest haben
das haben auch gehabt deshalb verstehe
ich jetzt nicht das er da so reagiert
wie gesagt sondern meine güte solle
adoptieren ja wissen dass man das letzte
hemd hat keine taschen und wissen was
wichtig ist im alltag dass ihr jemand
haben ist ja auch schon 78 da geht ja
auf die 80 zu jan soll er ist noch für
den aber ich habe leute gesehen die sind
von heute auf morgen auf einmal nicht
mehr für die winzer und dann kann er
mich jederzeit anrufen selbst zu
weihnachten kann ich im bild zeigen ich
habe immer einen tisch und lasse ihn am
tisch stehen der kann jederzeit kommen
immer offene tür ist egal was da gemacht
hat ist egal ob da rede ich bin gut da
so da kann kommen und ich habe immer
gesagt ich habe mir niemals schlecht
geht jung dann passt auch mit meinem
rollstuhl sitzen und man kann ja mal
passieren wie gesagt dann habe ich hier
noch eine villa da kannste hinkommt hier
gebe ich dir und dann kannst du da drin
wo brauchst du keine miete zahlen gar
nix an matisse an sich das ist super
großartig das ist sogar das wort
versöhnung der gläser sollten zu sorgen
seien aber so darf ein vater dich nicht
sein sohn ging kabine wenn der hund
schlägt er hat mag ich kaputt macht
ich war dumm aber es war so schön da so
ähnlich am ende dank seiner von anhalt
wird das gespräch hierbei live dieser
prinzen streit und unter prinzen ist man
dann eben wenn es ums erbe geht
irgendwie doch nicht für ganz geerdet
ist da läuft so wie bei allen anderen
auch da gibt es richtig zu